DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello, I'm
Dustin Kirkland, product
manager at Google, here
at KubeCon Copenhagen.
And I'm joined by one of
my colleagues, Dan Ciruli,
product manager for Istio.
Dan, every single
session about Istio
here is packed, people
falling out of the room.
Why is there so much excitement
about the Istio project?
DAN CIRULI: Well, I think
that the people who have been
adopting Kubernetes-- and
now, four years in, we've got
a bunch of people
who are using it--
have realized that
when you're deploying
lots of things in
lots of containers,
there's lots of communication
between those containers
and traffic into
those containers.
And Istio helps them
with that traffic.
When you've got
all that traffic,
you need to monitor
it, see what's
going on in your application.
You need to control it, where
all the requests are going,
and of course, you
need to secure it.
And people realized, as
they adopted Kubernetes,
that there wasn't anything
in the ecosystem that did
all of those things for them.
So Istio, they see us as what
will be the solution for all
those problems.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's great.
So people talk about
the zero problems
of standing up a Kubernetes,
and we help with that with GKE.
People talk about day
one, day two problems
getting those upgraded.
What you're talking about is
really a step beyond that.
Now you've got a Kubernetes.
How do you keep the
interesting workloads
working on top of Kubernetes?
DAN CIRULI: Yeah,
really, it's giving
a bunch of the tools
that are similar to what
RSREs have in operating
services at Google.
One of our first-- in
fact, the first customer
to go into production on
Istio was Descartes Labs.
They run a GKE.
And they love the move
to micro services,
but they found that after
they had adopted it,
when things slowed down and when
their app wasn't running well,
they had no idea why.
And they had
multiple dependencies
between their services
and no real way
to figure out what
those were or which
ones were causing the problems.
So they were an early
adopter of Istio,
and they instantly had a
service graph to tell them
where their dependencies were.
But most importantly, they
had the golden metrics.
They could see
what was going on.
where the high load
traffic was, where
the latencies were,
so they could
solve the problems.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So Istio must
touch a lot of different layers
in Kubernetes, certainly
networking, security, maybe
storage.
Can you just talk a little
bit about Istio interacts
with the rest of Kubernetes?
DAN CIRULI: Well,
ultimately, it's
built on top of Kubernetes.
We run our services
in Kubernetes.
We're dependent
on the API server.
And really, the
Kubernetes API server is--
everything that's building
on top of Kubernetes
is using the API server.
We are replacing or
offering alternative
as an ingress, Istio ingress,
featuring the envoy proxy,
which is a really, really
fast, very powerful proxy
that a lot of people are using.
And yeah, we're building on
top of that great Kubernetes
ecosystem.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: It's
all about the APIs, then.
Having good, clean,
well-defined APIs
and adhering to those APIs.
DAN CIRULI: Yeah, and what's
interesting about that
is that Istio itself helps
to govern those APIs.
So I think these two projects
are going to go together
really, really well.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And where do you
see Istio going next, as we
look out to the next six months
or so?
Can you give us a hint?
DAN CIRULI: Well, we're
at version 0.7 right now.
We are fast approaching,
we hope, 1.0.
We've got about 10
companies that we
know of in production today, and
so the code is getting there.
We've got stability in our API.
So we're getting
ready to declare 1.0.
And when we do that,
I think we're going
to see a wave of adoption.
And that's going to
be really exciting.
We'll see the ecosystem
start to build.
We've got a lot of partners
who are building integrations
right now.
So I see us going from
very early adopters to more
mainstream adoption and a big
ecosystem building around it.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And what's
the last hard problems
to solve before getting
to that proverbial 1.0?
Can you give us a
sense of like, what's
the big thorny
issues on your mind?
DAN CIRULI: Performance
is an issue.
We need to make sure that
people understand exactly how
much latency will this
add, how much more compute
is it going to add.
We've got the APIs
pretty stable right now.
We need to make sure
it is stable at scale.
Although we do have--
weather.com is running it
at about 400,000 requests
a second.
So we were already getting
into pretty good production
stability there.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
I was going to ask you
about scale, actually.
You jumped one step
ahead of me here.
But 400,000 containers-- all
right, sorry, 400,000 requests
per second is outstanding.
Does this deal help stave
off some of the work
that someone might have to do
otherwise, without a service
mesh in place to help with that
sort of scalability of traffic?
DAN CIRULI: What it does to
your scalability of traffic--
it allows you to understand
your system better.
Today, too many people
are scaling pods
on things like
memory consumption
or CPU, when in
reality, what you
might want to scale on
is the amount of traffic
that you're getting or what
your latencies are doing.
And so it's actually
giving better tools
to your operators to be able
to run those systems better.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Gotcha.
So earlier today, we've just
heard about the Stackdriver
announcements.
Can you tell us about how Istio
and Stackdriver might interact?
DAN CIRULI: Well, we already
have, in open source,
a mixer plug-in.
Mixer's one of the components
of Istio that gathers telemetry.
A plug-in today that will send
all of your Istio telemetry
to Stackdriver.
We've got some really
interesting things
in the works with that
team right now, some
stuff that we can't talk
about, but they announced
this Kubernetes thing.
We're already working on the
next big thing with those guys.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
OK, last question.
Security is on everyone's mind.
How does Istio help improve the
security model, or the policy
model, around Kubernetes itself?
DAN CIRULI: It gives everyone a
standard way, and an easy way--
first of all, an easy way
to get MTLS on every call.
We believe in a defense
in-depth strategy,
and even if your
perimeter is secure,
you should be securing
every single call.
So MTLS lets you identify every
single call that gets made,
and that, in turn, lets you put
an authorization policy on it.
So it allows
everyone in the world
to do what we do
at Google, which
is every single call is strongly
authenticated and authorized.
And as I said, it's a
defense in-depth strategy
that can't be beat.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's
really well thought out.
Thanks, Dan.
Appreciate your time.